last night at the 73rd Tony Awards in
New York City it wasn't only theater
being celebrated but pride as well and
the stars who walked the red carpet were
more than happy to share their support
for the LGBTQ community community
historically have excluded no one race
gender sexuality they open their arms to
everybody and historically always have
the Tony Awards have always shared the
message of inclusivity but this year it
couldn't be missed with the rainbow
floral wall which lined the red carpet
well it's beautiful I think it's so
wonderful that you can celebrate
celebrate that and and and make that
statement as an award show as a network
of it to be able to make that statement
to do it in a way that everybody feels
equal and proud is a wonderful thing I'm
so I'm very proud to support it
actress and activist Judith Light knows
that the Tony Awards and pride have
always gone hand in hand but this year
it is especially significant all the
things that have come out of this
community in support of the issues and
the lgbtq+ community and the HIV and
AIDS community they have been the ones
to step up and do something this doesn't
surprise me
I'm just thrilled that it's tonight and
fifty years of pride for the first time
world Pride will be hosted in the United
States in honor of the 50th anniversary
of Stonewall and its massive
significance in LGBTQ rights actor Bryan
Cranston shared the simple reminder of
opening ourselves up to differences we
can't live in a capsule we can't live in
our own little bubble we have to
spread the message of equality and love
and acceptance and in embracing
differences everywhere we go and
although we are seeing pride nearly
everywhere this month dr. Zachary Quinto
reminds us that there's still work to be
done well certainly we've made
tremendous strides in certain ways and
then in other ways we have a lot of work
to do but that's always the case with
social movements so marriage equality
you know doing away with Don't Ask Don't
Tell there have been incredible
political and social advances but
obviously we're living in a time when
there's an administration and a faction
of politics in this country would you
like to see all of that roll back not
only for the LGBT community but also for
women and minorities of all kinds so I
think we have to stay vigilant we have
to stay active we have to stay engaged
and visibility is a huge part of that so
what are your plans for Pride Month how
are you gonna celebrate and show your
pride what do you think of the rainbow
floral Tony Awards red carpet let me
know in the comments below and don't
forget to subscribe to ET Canada's
YouTube page
you